سمع في الجزء العلوي من البرنامج أن
الرئيس السابق انتقد مرة أخرى
السناتور الجمهوري ميت رومني من بين
آخرين خلال خطابه الذي ألقاه في لجنة CPAC الليلة الماضية ،
لكن السناتور رومني كان مشغولًا بالتعامل مع
مشكلة أكبر تسببت في
ذهابه إلى فريق المستشفى
ريان ينضم إلينا النبلاء.  ما
حدث بشكل جيد
اليوم عاد السناتور رومني إلى
واشنطن أندرسون وتعرض
للضرب
بشكل واضح في عين سوداء عدة جروح في شفتيه
وقال للصحفيين إنه جاء بعد
سقوط
مع أطفاله في بوسطن خلال
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع
قال رومني إن الخريف  كان
خطيرًا لدرجة أنه فقد
وعيه واضطر إلى نقله إلى
المستشفى ،
حيث أُعطي عددًا من الغرز من
حاجبه طوال الطريق من خلال
جفنه ،
لكنه قال إنه بخير لم يتم
إدخاله إلى المستشفى ولم يكن مضطرًا
للبقاء  بين عشية
وضحاها تم إطلاق سراحه في النهاية ولكن آه يمكنك
أن
ترى بقايا هذا الحادث
على وجهه
كما قلت قبل تعرضه للضرب بشكل
سيء وسمعت أنه  حتى يشعر
بروح الدعابة بعد السقوط
، كإشارة إلى أنه يتعافى
من هذا بسرعة ، كان قادرًا على المزاح
حول ذلك عندما سأل الصحفيون لأول مرة
ما هو الخطأ ، قال رومني مازحا أنه
ارتكب خطأ حضور
cpac وكما لاحظت و  كما لاحظت
أنه تعرض للهجوم بلا هوادة في
cpac خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ، فهو في الواقع لم
يذهب إلى cpac وكان ذلك مجرد مزحة ولكن من
الواضح أن عضو مجلس الشيوخ من ولاية يوتا لا يزال
يتمتع بروح الدعابة على الرغم من هذه الإصابة
ولا يزال قادرًا على العمل
أوه نعم بالتأكيد أه كان أه
أتى إلى العمل وكان قادرًا على الإدلاء بأصواته
وكل شيء اليوم لذا لا توجد مشكلة هناك